i don't want to get into the politics of
gun ownership i'm british i'm not
exactly qualified but i will say that
switzerland has a very high rate of
people who own guns and a pretty low
rate of people who are hurt by guns this
is the brunei sow shooting range about
two hours from zurich and i think it's
the best possible demonstration of the
attitude that switzerland has to both
firearms and firearms safety you fire
your rifle from there
the targets are over there and in
between them is a major highway
and it's safe
recently
rifle shooting is a national sport in
switzerland service in the military is
compulsory for men albeit these days
with the choice to take on civilian
public service work instead for those
who do choose military service a lot of
them decide to keep their firearm when
they finish which means that yes there
are a lot of people with guns in
switzerland but they've pretty much all
had thorough training in how to use them
the restriction sport for bond
hot circle 100 6000 milk leader
and industries and global trade
commercial millionaires
all right so i you could lift that oh
yeah all the way down
okay
okay your target this is number seven
number seven i thought this was a
magnifier it's not a magnifier you just
have to be very accurate weird hobbin
yes you
look yeah the target and push
i think i'd have missed that but
yeah okay all right let's try it for
real if you're shooting a rifle here
you're lying down and you cannot see the
road anything you fire that's travelling
fast enough to go over that wall just
can't hit the road there just isn't a
possible trajectory for a bullet that
can damage anything other than the hill
and of course the targets
that goes up against my shoulder and
depending on yes and gets held with this
hand here
and i just have to line up
look at the target and to push
missed gas the recoil was going to hit
me in the eye there this mower
okay
five i'm going the other way now
oh yeah hey that's a 10. this is a pin
yes
go on there in the end
[Applause]
about
foreign
i'll take that that's about 56 out of
100 and i got i got one in the bullseye
i'll take that thank you very much thank
you welcome now there is the reasonable
question well what if someone were to
stand up then they could see and hit the
road well again training it's unlikely
to happen and also breaking the safety
rules when you're surrounded by
military-trained firearm enthusiasts is
not a great plan what if you stand up is
basically the same question as oh what
if you decide to point the rifle at
someone you will very rapidly not be
holding a rifle anymore if someone wants
to cause harm with a gun this is not the
way they do it joining a rifle club
getting all the permits and then
deciding to throw all that away to take
a pot shot to card just once
not sure there's anyone who's sensible
enough to do the first bits of that and
unhinged enough to do the last part
and if there is they've never made it
here
which is once again and we haven't
knocked me
see
you